[Music]  I'm sure they told you about the  sacrifices you'd make but none of us  could have ever predicted this  now if there's any chance of putting the  pieces of our city back together then  this is all up to you  when we first arrived this place was  destroyed but over time we can make it  our home  from here we launch countless missions  across the city in search of others  doctors former cops engineers people who  can help us rebuild the world  out there you'll need all your training  and equipment with every battle one  you'll become stronger  with every challenge met you will gain  power  other agents have set up safe houses  throughout the city you'll need to team  up with them and work together we have  to rely on each other's strengths to  save what remains and give New York a  fighting chance that's something we  thought was lost hope you are here for a  reason  no mistake  we are taking this city back  [Music]  you  [Music]